not that long ago we were a tiny little
startup with a crazy idea and here we
are getting ready to go public so that
was coinbase's ceo just a few weeks
before the company scored an 85 billion
valuation in its stock market debut
since it was founded in 2012 the company
has grown to be the largest
cryptocurrency exchange in the u.s
thanks in part to its focus on making
crypto accessible it's just going to be
sort of an easy
seamless way for people to just get into
crypto and trade it that was their idea
it helped the company bring in record
revenue in 2021 as more traders joined
the platform
but as bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies fell coinbase's share
value fell along with it exposing deeper
issues with its business practices and
culture
so
what went wrong
in 2021 the crypto industry was booming
coinbase
public listing on its own was driving a
lot of enthusiasm for the rest of the
market this was seen as a bellwether
news event
the explosion in crypto drove more
people including many retail traders to
coinbase's platform and that drove up
revenue in a big way
most of the company's money comes from
trading fees which it charges two types
of traders first retail more basically
you know mom and pop young kids people
like you and me people just kind of
doing this out there on their own and
second institutional brokerage houses
pension funds hedge funds i mean people
who are out there who have a business
that is predicated on your trading
assets in the capital market much of
coinbase's trading volume comes from
these traders but most of their revenue
comes from these ones who make up its
core customer base in the second quarter
of 2021 90 of coinbase's 2 billion net
revenue was made from retail
transactions alone spurred on by a
growing user base coinbase set its
sights on growth they beefed up on
hiring aiming to catch up to competitors
that had a wider span of crypto assets
and products between the end of the
first and third quarters it added more
than a thousand employees in october
coinbase announced it would launch its
own nft marketplace and in november the
share price shot to a high point as the
value of bitcoin peaked but there was
trouble ahead especially for a company
that relied on crypto enthusiasm these
things are all lashed very very tightly
to sentiment in the crypto markets in
the stock market
stocks like coinbase become a proxy for
the crypto markets and that's why you
see the stock prices track crypto so
closely as the fed began to shift its
monetary policy to tackle inflation many
professional investors started to pull
out of assets that they considered
riskier crypto became sort of one asset
in a larger portfolio if you're a
professional trader you make you you buy
bonds you buy stocks you buy commodities
you buy currencies and now you were
buying crypto so you were slotting
crypto in among those different assets
and where it ended up being slotted for
most of them was it was a risk asset it
was a highly valid item in april
coinbase's share price dropped steeply
as trading volume fell and analysts
slashed estimates for earnings
transactions were down and retail
traders were pulling out of the market
some were huddling shorthand for holding
on for dear life it means that they were
sitting on their cryptocurrencies trying
to ride out price declines and hoping to
come out on top at the other end that
also means that they were making fewer
trades in transactions the main things
that coinbase relies on to make money
the stock price continued to slide in
may when the company reported losses in
the first quarter when you started to
see business results come in and the
business results were really bad i think
that's when people started to realize
that this was not just one of you know
crypto's sort of periodic common spasms
as trading continued to slow and revenue
fell larger problems within the company
were exposed
certainly early in 2022 it was hard to
tell how severe the sell-off was going
to be there wasn't a lot of panic and
you saw companies like coinbase they
kept hiring they were in expansion mode
and they just kept running with that
despite the fact that the prices started
to fall the company hadn't built up
other streams of revenue and time to
make up for falling profits the nft
marketplace they had announced in
october didn't materialize until april
just as the nft market was flatlining
the platform did just 4.2 million in
transactions between when it went live
in april and the beginning of august
coinbase has also offered things like
staking and custodial services now
especially it's just a really hard time
to try to build new businesses in the
middle of you know completely down
market
in early june a petition purportedly
from coinbase employees was posted to
another crypto site it called to oust
several executives over the company's
performance armstrong tweeted that the
petition was really dumb on multiple
levels i think probably issues that were
inside the company that largely were
tapered over because times were so good
in 2021 started to emerge in 2022.
a few weeks later the company announced
it would cut its workforce by about 18
to reduce spending its employee account
had grown to nearly 5 000 and coinbase
ran into more trouble in july as federal
authorities charged a former product
manager from the company with insider
trading lawyers for the former product
manager said that the charges were
meritless
the sec also took the position that
several of the crypto assets traded on
the company's platform are classified as
securities
the company which isn't licensed to
operate as a securities exchange denied
that the assets qualify
by the end of quarter two the retail
trading volume fell by 74 from the high
in quarter four of 2021.
to make up for lost ground coinbase
plans to continue to grow its other
streams of revenue
in june it launched a derivatives
product that allows traders to bet on
the price of an underlying asset the
company announced a partnership with
money management firm blackrock in
august which could help increase the
number of institutional investors that
use the platform
coinbase says that it has built up more
client requested products and is seeing
a strong uptake
armstrong told cnbc in august that the
company is planning on increasing its
earnings from subscriptions and services
which made up about 18 of its quarter
two revenue
we're realizing that trading fees is not
going to be that thing that you know
it's going to be it's still going to be
a major part of our business in 10 years
from now even 20 years from now but i'd
like to get to a place where more than
50 of our revenue is subscription and
services businesses across the crypto
industry have been impacted by the
downturn but competitors like binance
and ftx have continued to grow and are
gaining market share of spot trading
however since neither company is public
it's not clear how much their earnings
have currently been impacted by the
market
in its quarter two letter to
shareholders coinbase said that it lives
by the mantra it's never as good as it
seems and it's never as bad as it seems
and that it is an all-weather company
with experience in navigating crypto
asset price cycles
the company's share price has seen a
small increase in recent months coinbase
says that it continues to take a
long-term view and remains focused on
building for the future